you are listening to the hot breath
podcast I am your host comedian Joel
Byers and welcome to your weekly guide
to comedy mastery with melanie comarcho
that's your baby I'll just join you over
here we can if are you good you okay you
cool to share the yeah I had no idea I
figured that you were off camera
interviewing okay no like DJ Vlad or
something okay I want my time to I know
I see okay so we just make sure Melanie
come March oh yes that's correct
not Camacho I'm sure what's the worst
somebody's like butchered your name I'm
a Racha I'm comin atcha watch oh yeah if
I could see a little sound check there
for you just lovely it's Melanie Camacho
and you're listening to hot breath hot
breath with Joel buyers with Joel buyers
that's a great start to an interview
when the the guest is like okay so I'm
only with so-and-so I don't know I've
done like five of these today so I don't
know I can imagine yeah I had no she
ended many podcast though no like you
got into a call-in yeah that's why I'm
working on my movie so out of really I'm
not trying to go up I'm so mad
overbooked myself for October cuz I want
it to be home but I booked myself and
forgot oh my god I'm supposed to be in
North Carolina out of 12 in the third
change I said yes are you booking
everything yourself and we're starting
to help we're all okay yeah I pretty
much booked myself um you know I can do
to me the agents that I have worked with
are not as aggressive as I am no okay so
I'm calling and people are calling me
and it's like why would I give ten
percent for you to negotiate what I can
negotiate yeah
and a lot of times I get more than what
they call me back with I'm like okay
call my agent and then my agent will
call me with that number and I'm like no
that's not what I told them
how'd it dropped twenty-five hundred Wow
so it's like no I'll do it myself
what are some tips you have for
negotiating rates like that I mean what
do you think you're worth I see a lot of
the other comics and they're making
double triple what I'm getting and I'm
like okay I might not have the name and
it goes by like your internet followings
can make your price go up TV and film
definitely make your price go up I don't
have that right now
all I have is you know me guest
appearing on like the comedy shows and
stuff like that but there's no movie
deal or anything so but I still can
negotiate a pretty decent price you got
to know what your worth is is what you
got to know sometimes I'll negotiate a
price and you'll say yes so fast I'd be
like I got more money so sometimes so I
start big I started like 15,000 okay and
then work depends on what you're where
we at if we're doing a theater or a
comedy club and then you know of course
they're gonna we're gonna be negotiating
and they're trying to get it down so
when I start up cuz I know they're gonna
try to go down so it might end up being
10 like I want it to be you just
overshoot what you actually want Zach
and then work them down yeah exactly and
then it you you [ __ ] them
well I just got 24 the last gig knowing
damn well you ain't got no point they
don't know that they don't know so that
you can do use that and you know just
whatever you think you're worth
is you know a lot of the comics will go
and do these tours for grand and I'm not
mad you know if you don't have a name
you're not out there it's a way to get
out there and you know a grand is pretty
good a show for somebody just starting
yeah you were fifteen hundred with
Martin I start now oh yeah call me Jim
was 1515 but we were doing four shows a
weekend so I was coming home with $6,000
which I had never made that kind of
money in my life right now
I was in aerospace before I started
doing comedy I was on an assembly line
bringing home like I might have got 1500
every two weeks and that was before
taxes man so it was like oh my god I'm
buying [ __ ] you know I'm blowing money
and then you find out uh you need to
bank money for when there is no tour
right so that first after I did tape def
Comedy Jam probably I went six months
with no tour and then Chris Tucker
called and said hey I'm about to go and
do this Friday after next tour or some
kind of tour connected cuz Friday was
hot at the time so we went out and there
it was again so that was wonderful
ya know Martin didn't give me 1500 thank
god martin pays real well oh yeah you've
toured with like the 1% of comedies I
had with billionaires I've been so
blessed so blessed
Martin Lawrence Katt Williams Chris
Tucker Maxwell the singer called me one
year and I didn't believe it was him he
was like yeah I'd like you to open up
for my tour and I'm like yeah click
who's this plan and then they'd call
back and I saw the caller ID said
William Morris so I guess he had his
agent to call and I was like why and
then they told me how much and I was
like I love you but I can't do that even
Maxwell you knew your worth yeah then
how'd mean cry that was a great tool but
I'm not going for that no way so I they
gave me a little bit more and I said and
then you William Morris will get the
money after expenses is what I'll pay
you huh and so everybody agreed it was a
great tour we had so much fun and I've
been so blessed that all the guys are
respectful they treat me like sisters
it's never been a situation where I was
uncomfortable being ever know and I'm
always been the only lady except for the
Katt Williams tour I was the only lady
on tour with these guys and they were
protecting me like I was their sister so
that was really cool what are some of
your favorite like tour memories yummy
cool stories one time when I was on tour
with Chris Tucker Prince called Chris
and said hey can you come over to the
house after the show
like and Chris was like hey you want to
go today yeah I want to go to Prince's
house so we went to Prince's house and
that was absolutely amazing
here we toured the whole house he even
has like a club in on the property so it
was amazing I loved it and then one
night I'm at The Improv Hollywood and
Prince is there so The Improv is calling
me hey princess here you might want to
get over here she never got dressed so
fast my dam like I'm running lights get
into Hollywood and I got there in time
to perform in front of them so those are
some great memories for me Wow in the
private jets and all that won't even go
there private jet this is not this is
like I'm trying to play it off like oh
this is something I'm used to but in my
mind I'm like oh my god I'm on a private
jet flying all over the country because
I flew private with Chris Martin and Kat
all of them and it was all amazing and
and I oh god we had so much fun with
these guys I remember one time when I
was on tour with Kat we had went to a
restaurant and we all ordered food right
and so I ordered a steak trying to be
different from everybody else and here
comes the biggest steak I've ever seen
in my life so when it hit the table
everybody's laughing because they know
you know I eat like a bird she's not
everybody's laughing pointing at me so
Kat comes over and whispers in my ear
$500 says you can't eat that whole steak
Wow I think we sat there for extra hour
because I was eating that stink
I was getting that 500 I'm golden I got
it all down and I got that 500 it was
the coolest thing ever
is what's so interesting about Kat is
like he has like this camera persona
uh-huh but everything I've heard behind
the scenes has been good he is the
biggest heart he's a greatest guy
I've watched him we did a college one
time where I watched Kat throw $5,000 to
the audience and it came to my show and
gave a couple of comics like money see
just for performing big heart the guy is
heart ever I don't care what they say or
you see he's a really nice guy and very
articulate this guy reads a lot
interesting very smart what do you think
that it like why is it like he's seen as
one way but then behind the scenes he's
like I'm clueless I can't figure it out
either yeah I don't know I wish he'd
show that other side people would see I
wish to keep people could see more of
the other side of cat because there's a
really good side to him that a lot of
people don't even know about but if
you're in his circle you know you know
he's got a really big heart good even
when we were on tour my mom passed and
so I of course wasn't gonna go on the
road that weekend he paid me as if I
worked that weekend yeah Wow and he
still replaced me so he paid that person
and me Wow yeah so that was like thank
you so much what was your response to
him on v-103 I'm sure you saw as long de
which actually went on tour with early
on in the game right yeah mark I'm Wanda
me and sure when I first started just
Wanda and Shirley Underwood took me
under there took me under their wing I
had all of ten minutes before def Comedy
Jam and they took me under their wing
and we went traveling and they took me
all over the country I was like yeah
that was fun but you know Edmonton but
he said good things about me no I think
Tiffany getting everything she deserves
she's a really sweetheart she's a great
girl congratulations on your Emmy
Tiffany and she's there to open the
doors for us you know there's no comics
have gotten to to me to where she is
right now except for maybe Whoopi
Goldberg and Whoopi you know she's a
neat guy yeah but and they and
congratulations to John Legend the
youngest he got ever incredible yeah
isn't that Wow I hope to be the oldest
one ever I believe I want to ëgod or
something give me anything I haven't got
an award I got one when I first started
comedy I will learn this thing called
the Soul Train Comedy Awards mm-hmm
and I was up against comics I have never
met when I first started doing comedy
shurl Underwood Wanda Sykes they were
all you know they had all been doing it
for a while and I was a new jack here I
come and I win this thing
it was I was I couldn't believe I was
like what okay
this standing ovation - yeah they were
like okay there's no sex and no
belittling no degrading other people's
race is not like okay so I ended the my
set with well I know they said we
couldn't do it but I want to talk about
dick for a minute and I we had just got
a new mayor named dick Reardon and once
I said no no dick Reardon everybody went
crazy and that was the end of you know
and then they told me I won the next day
but I haven't that was 20 years ago I'm
ready for another something yeah you
start in 1992 right 1992 I started and
then I taped my first Def Jam in 93
you've been on this fast-track I'm still
here you know I've been torn they still
calling me I'm still working thank God
I'm here at the Atlanta comedy theater
this weekend so if you're in the area
the Atlanta Comedy Theatre 4650 Jimmy
Carter Boulevard
I'm bringing the funny we don't talk
about everything and it's so much to
talk about come on me too I got to start
a new movement not dammit not me yeah I
don't play that they know better who to
come to
you've never you've never got me to
never and I'm looking at somebody's
women I'm like somebody tried to mess
with you nobody's even looking my way
what is going on oh you know really I
don't know I don't know button what do
you attribute to being on tour with so
many people and being able to sustain
this success for this long I said you
know I tried to like I said keep my
mouth and my legs closed mmm that helps
a lot you know don't try to and stay
humble a lot of these comics go on tour
with these major comics and they might
have a great set that night and they're
like I was funnier than he was so that's
where you really mess up shut up stay
humble because you might have been
funnier but who came to see you nobody
your name isn't even on the bill you are
here it says such-and-such and
and you were blessed enough to get
chosen as a friend oh and that's where a
lot of comics oh he kicked me off he's
doer cuz I was funnier than him no
because you got cocky that's why you got
kicked off to her button cuz she was
funnier so what's your funny he's trying
to shine light on you but you can't put
one ass in the seat so let's keep it
real it's about who can put asses in the
seat that's why these internet comics
are blowing up like them because they
got a million three three million
followers they figure if you got three
million followers at least 500,000 is
gonna follow you into the club or the
theater or the TV show so when you see
these comics coming up because they're
on the Internet okay so what they're not
funny they're selling out you're selling
out they're putting asses in a seat and
that's all this business is about it
used to be a day when it was all about
who's the funniest but today is who can
put the asses in the seat that's what
it's about today a lot of oh geez in the
game kind of resent that those internet
cats hey come on I mean I'm hoping it's
a face but they said that the reality TV
was a phase and it's been what 20 years
and it's still going on so you know it's
just a new day and we have to you know
if you can't beat them join them so
we're gonna have to get on Instagram and
do videos all day every day and stuff
like that I'm guessing but it depends
cuz my age demographic the 40 to 50 year
olds they're not on there like that
those are the Millennials for
20-something years old that so what I
did was I wrote directed and produced my
own film I can't wait for Hollywood to
put me on I put my own self on and I
went out and it's an ultra low budget
which means it's ain't a lot of money
involved and I grabbed every comic in LA
they all supported me and came out is
it's Jay Anthony Brown Tiffany Haddish
bro man from the fifth floor AJ Johnson
Kym Whitley cocoa brown mmm it's just
these are just some of the many many
Damon Wayans Damon Williams I'm sorry
and Marvin Dixon it cocoa brownies
so many comics I can't even name but
they all came out it's a film about I
try to do movies I write scripts shoes
so I wrote this and some more scripts
but this is about a group of thieves in
LA so they're stealing clothes bringing
them to the hot house for me to sell to
the public so it's like a Robin Hood
type of thing we steal from the rich and
we give to the poor right so you can get
whatever you want you tell me where you
saw it at and what size you are in three
days we got you you know till my
boosters and they'll go out and get it
so it's called boosters rest stop
boosters and boosters LA is what I'm
gonna change the name to nobodies
boosters yes and it's funny and I can't
wait we're an editing now so hopefully
it'll be somewhere that's my hope I'm
gonna pray that because of the star
power in this film that they're gonna
pick it up immediately I'm hoping it's a
bidding war yeah for it so we'll see you
know that game though like even you you
taped your special and then it doesn't
come out to like two years later it is
such a process it is but thank God he
has put a few people in my life so I got
a few little connections yeah yeah and
I'm gonna use every one of them there
you know people have approached me and
said hey I heard you were doing a movie
when you finish editing give me make me
your first call and I'm like yeah I sure
will so you know that doesn't mean
they're gonna buy it but it'll be their
first call you know it seems like a lot
of your career has been organic and just
oh every you've just kind of just
blessing yeah like who's managing you
God God is managing me he wants 10% just
like an agent and he's getting me some
really great work i I have done more
tours than any comic more major tours
than any comic in the country so he's
like well alright yeah maybe more than
that and I've I toured some other tours
like I did this tour called ladies night
out where I hosted like jagged-edged Dru
Hill Casey and Jojo all the the singing
the guys that sing so we took that all
over the south and that was a great tour
to again the only lady with all these
guys
so I was like I put me in another hotel
because the group he's coming after them
was just doing too much I died and me
look I'm not with any oh really
I'm just working here please don't what
about your groupie zone you don't get
group oh you know my groupies I get them
at the club
sure I do I thought smack about me in
and they're lined up a petition let me
get you some new material yeah I'm like
okay yeah right
my room number is no cuz see I don't do
comedians but a fan nobody's gonna
believe you you can't bring your phone
to my room mmm yeah and you'll actually
absolve her do talk about you'll
actually get material from fans where
they'll come and tell you a story in
your like I sure well I'll just make
that meet in the mansion on stage you
better believe it I sure do cuz I've
never had a guy with big balls that's
something some fan told me if a joke is
so funny
you ballers have never cut all my life
I'm the bra and all like that that's
what I loved about I have forgot about
the bra joke I haven't done that in so
long I think that was a tag - it is it
is why should I
I think how did your joke go it was oh
it was about the feet you guys making
having sex with the future socks on why
should I have cold titties where you got
more iffy I'm not gonna take off my bra
if you don't take off your socks this I
mean with my bra is not in the way of
what we about to tell you that right now
what's something wrong I hadn't seen you
perform I saw you perform at the old
uptown many years ago okay and now
getting to see you again you know I'm a
little over eight years in the game so
now getting to watch you and observe you
at this level and just your writing and
it's just like tag tag tag tag like you
have so many tags to your jokes I tried
not to let them breathe yeah I can tell
when they're yeah I'm nervous okay
and the people are like they're
listening that's why they're quiet I was
like okay cuz sometimes it take them a
minute to get to joke and you some
comics you know when they're telling
their jokes and you don't get it they
start laughing to get you to laugh yeah
they're laughing it more at their own
material than the audience a little
cheat on stage laugh yourself haha
Danelle okay
I don't want to do that that's make you
last not good form I'm the old school
I'm an actual stand up there are so many
kinds of comedians you know you got your
singing comedians you got your dancing
comedians your really physical they're
running back and sweating like a dog by
the time they finish with their act I
just stand there but the entire stand in
it and you're just boom boom boom there
you might get two or three steps I got
maybe one or two jokes that I actually
have to move around and that's it so
when you are developing your material
like let's say and the the battery might
die so I may need to reset but we'll
just see so like a fan comes up to and
does and tells you about this like like
this big ball story how do you then
develop that into like to become stage
ready what is the process from
translating take it out onto the stage
and and test it on them out throw it in
with some other sex jokes and then I'll
just throw it in
oh you ever had a guy with big balls
mm-hmm and then instead of saying my
friend told me I'll be like yeah I met
one the other day and then first person
how I do it yeah I mean like
everything's about me instead of my fans
even some jokes I tell about my friends
they were like i'ma kick your ass you
know it's them I said everybody only
person knows issue is you everybody else
thinks just me so that's how I pin to
paper like we write stuff do I'll write
it out what I'll do nowadays because
it's so easy as I record on my phone
interesting oh man I got to do some
material like I I had the uber from hell
on the way to the airport from my house
in LA to the airport this I've never had
an uber driver this was the most ghetto
ratchet we're driving I didn't even get
she didn't even get one star out of me
and I was like oh my god I gotta do some
material on this she's talking on the
phone while she's with me on speaker
about her car being repossessed is that
the conversation you want to have in
front of me she doesn't know who I am
and you know she doesn't know she's
about to be part of my act you never
know who's in your car and then she's
got an attitude you know what people get
in here funky and bougie just cuz I
Drive for over don't mean I'm gonna get
out
car and help you with your bags I was
like why I said well they probably do
that so they can get five stars okay mmm
and a compliment I said and sometimes
you get a tip it's all about your
attitude yeah you know you act like we
doin you a favor you doing us a favor
but you doing we doing you one two right
yeah cuz you wouldn't be driving uber if
you wasn't broke so you in here trying
to do these 599 rides with uber so you
can pay your light bill stop we not
gonna win this ain't even your car is it
it's ubers car right now feels
repossessed yeah no no they churro car
was repossessed now she's driving uber
it's car oh no she said it was her mom's
car I'm like wow so you and your mom are
driving uber Wow Gary I'm so blessed
blessed blessed yeah you're blessed to
have successful daughters yeah
successful daughters they don't drive
uber
yeah one's a social worker write nothing
down about that hey if you do what you
got to do and see if it beats going on
the polls so gone and try it at uber
hello but I'm just blessed that I
haven't I've been 25 years in the game
I've never had to go to Trader Joe's or
anything I've been just I've been able
to maintain a roof over my head for the
entire time and from the jump though
like a year and you're on them that
you're like doing it almost seemed like
you didn't really have that open mic
grind just like in the trenches almost
year I did I did and I entered this
comedy competition and that Club used to
give me so much love because it was the
one I started with and then I tried some
new material and downhill it went other
people one everybody you know thought I
was gonna win the competition but I came
in like third place but then a couple of
months later I won that Soul Train
Comedy Awards and it paid 25,000 and
this only paid like a hundred so I was
good 25,000 to win that to win that Soul
Train Comedy Awards it was like huh
I love it well my listeners know what I
love about asking comics is you talk
about this set and you went and then
down and went
I want to I love here in the highs but I
also love here in the lows so what is a
show you've done that like you got
boudoir epicly bombed like you know what
I got booed at Showtime at the Apollo
okay with the best of the best is food
is Showtime at the Apollo but they
didn't boo me off
okay booed and then I went straight to
the ladies ladies I mean it was like so
I made it through so that was probably
one of my scariest I do to joke once
about guys going to the doctor taking a
urine test I was like how do you guys do
it I mean you can't get all you'll be in
that big-ass toilet how you do it in
that little bitty Cup and all the guys
with they were doing the [ __ ] out of me
oh my god oh my god and they booed me
off that night I was like okay I was
doing the game I was like okay bye I'll
see you later
but I've been so blessed to just have a
lot of good shows I haven't had one
thank God in any major market where I
got booed or sometimes we have a show
that we weren't happy with but the
audience was I know you've ever you
would like tang I didn't go but the
audience is after the show they're like
oh man you were funny is it yeah yeah so
you know yeah interesting ones where you
don't feel good about it and then people
come up after and that they're I loved
it they loved it they loved it yeah
you're like all right you guys should
have seen me last night I was really
funny you know so 25 years in you would
mentioned almost you get nervous with
silence on stage that's not overcome
every time I hit the stage I'm nervous I
pray before I saw your ring last night
before the show these guys yeah you
don't know you don't know what the
audience is going through you don't know
if they haven't family issues or if
they're drunk or whatever is going on
you know you just got a hope that once I
get them with that first joke I kind of
got them uh-huh but you don't know so
I'm nervous every time and to me if
you're not nervous something's wrong
you're cocky that's when you go out
there about to destroy this and they be
like boo
so stay humble what about the the
community work would like like Martin
and Kat and Chris is it their
performance is it always pretty much the
same order they do a lot of like
improvising our dad is the king of
improv improvising is he I watched him
we did I think it was just for Laughs in
Montreal one year this guy ended up
doing like 20 minutes on the ride into
the city world the festival and
destroyed that if you saw his special
his last special I think he did 15 20
minutes on whatever city he was in in
Florida I think they had just had a
hurricane Johnson there might have been
jacks yeah yeah it's his improv is he's
a master at it so yeah I've seen him do
really good I mean they all do well I
haven't been on a show with any one of
them that they didn't have a good show I
mean like I just said we think we didn't
have a good shot
yeah they lined up waiting to see him
you know and some of them could say boo
I mean Martin's at the point he could
say blue and they're yeah they come
especially when you have a built-in
autistic man to see he's a legend
yeah I love him so it's no he can't do
no wrong I love being around veteran
comedians and absorbing as much
knowledge as possible I believe it and
what what have you absorbed from working
with them and to stay humble
they taught me stay humble to be nervous
is a great thing I got the opportunity
to do a show in front of Richard Pryor
one night at the Comedy Store in LA and
it was amazing and I had the best ten
minutes ever in front of Richard Pryor a
melon so good and everybody was like you
should have did more time you should
have did more time and Richard heard I'm
telling me that and he told me he said
come here let me tell you something and
I was like what and he was like cuz I
was kind of scared he was in a
wheelchair Larry what is he gonna tell
me he was like always leave them wanting
more
it's like that's what the legend told me
so forget what you knew jacksie
you don't know what you're talking about
so yeah that was a great for him to tell
me always leave Morton more so doing not
enough time is not bad oh my god not a
bad thing prior Richard Pryor it was
amazing I've gotten I got a chance to do
comedy thank God in front of people I
had no I I did a show last week in front
of Mack swing Maxine Waters hmm and
she's like here's my number whenever
you're performing in LA call my office
that's why I can come what what I'm
doing at the time join a cruise and I'm
doing some dirty jokes because I don't
see Farrakhan sitting there I'm like
feeling some type of way to next day cuz
Americana and his whole team are there
he's all his security and I'm scared I'm
in the lunch room the next day nervous
and I was like would you please tell mr.
Farrakhan that I am so sorry I did not
see him there I didn't want to be
disrespectful and he was like oh I was
laughing on the inside sweetie you're
good yes so it's so cool to see you this
long in the game and still it's like
you're just as enthusiastic as if this
was like your first year yeah I love
what I do is such a blessing I love my
fans I love talking to people who don't
know who I am
especially like sometimes at a show I
was talking to this one girl she was had
no idea who I was and then once I got
onstage but she was gay so I do this
joke did you see it last night yeah yeah
yeah she just was so excited that I
she's jumping up I can see her in the
audience because she didn't know who I
was and I wasn't gonna say oh I'm the
opening act you'll see in a minute and
that was that's the coolest thing when
they don't know who you are and then you
perform in front of them crying last
night yeah crying and I was just like oh
my god did you see the one that came to
the show on the Walker she's in a walker
she it broke her leg or something if
she's pushing the thing coming like that
I got a picture I said we got to put
this on Instagram look at oh my god
they came out for you it was a Thursday
night and it was like cracked out
practically sold out yeah tables yeah on
a Thursday VIP they didn't want to pay
that $30
they paid the rest everybody else filled
it up so it's cool
well congratulations and honestly thank
you for doing this thank you for having
me you guys support make sure make sure
you tune in to his podcast is it weekly
or daily weekly every Monday every
Monday 8:00 a.m. check it out thank you
so much yeah before we get out of here
is there anything else you want the
world to know um you guys just got to
catch me um I'll be on the Capitol Jazz
Cruise let me see let's start off with
October 6 I'm in LA doing a comedy of
doing the comedy Union the elect the
12th or 13th I'll be in Clayton North
Carolina wherever that is somewhere near
Raleigh the 20th I'll be at the Music
Hall in Detroit and the 27th I'll be
doing a show with Talent the funny man
in New York so you guys catch me follow
me on instagram melanie comarcho
CEO ma r CH oh and Melanie the way
Joel's mom was send it is it ma LAN ie
Melanie my mama didn't try to change and
put the black spin on it melanie
comarcho
she's trying to make sure I got a job so
yeah great job
yes well thank you melanie comarcho
thanks real hot breath thank you so much
for having me
all right Tony and Joel you guys we out
of here
[Music]